how do you give a driverless car a
driving test
researchers have a new way to test out
an ai's driving skills it works by
surrounding the car with other AIS
these ones are virtual simulations and
they've been trained to be terrible
drivers
[Music]
the world is waiting for the first fully
autonomous car around 2015 now so a
number of companies announced that they
will be able to produce autonomous
vehicle in mass amount by 2020 and and
now we are 2023 we do not have any
commercial available autonomous vehicle
yet Henry Liu has been looking forward
to his own driverless car for some time
in a true autonomous vehicle you could
play games on your commute save on fuel
costs and send your kids off without
worrying it's dear to my heart because I
have two young children one is 17 and
one is 15 and if we do have autonomous
vehicle at this time then they don't
have to drive or feel safer for them but
to make sure these cars are safe we need
to be confident that they can handle any
situation they come across and that
takes a lot of testing a major bottom
lag for the Thomas vehicle department is
the high cost and time required to test
the safety performance just think about
this for human drivers we might have
accidents for every half million to a
million miles and one fatality per 100
million miles
so if you want to validate and the
autonomous vehicle the safety
performance is better than human drivers
then statistically you rule and need
billions of miles but you can't just let
prototype cars loose on real roads
potentially endangering other Road users
so Henry and his team in Michigan in the
USA are developing a new kind of test to
make sure autonomous vehicles are safe
they've combined a real test track with
augmented reality obstacles these
obstacles are invisible to us but feed
into the car's sensors so the AI reacts
as if they were completely real I was
one of the test drivers and sometimes it
could be a little nourished because that
the vehicle could perform a heartbreak
just to avoid some of the front objects
to really put the driverless car to the
test the virtual environment has to be
full of challenges you can generate all
sorts of things right so you can
generate animals you know a deer a
pedestrian a bicycle list and see harm
that almost vehicle react these
obstacles are generated by the team's AI
based on real-life data but in a
realistic simulation dangerous events
don't happen that often so to really put
the car through its Paces they skewed
that training data to focus on the kind
of dangerous driving which is not
frequently seen but could be deadly we
can't buy any safety critical cases
together and that's why we call it dance
learning because we intensify the
information we have then we use this
dance learning approach to train the
surrounding Vehicles not that
pre-trained autonomous vehicle to learn
that at what moment perform what manure
to challenge the autonomous vehicle the
result is a simulation filled with
terrible drivers and surprising
obstacles and what's more because these
situations are generated by an AI and
not programmed they don't just perform a
fixed set of challenging Maneuvers they
can generate dangerous events with
variety and complexity and learn how to
best put the autonomous vehicle to the
test that's why we caught AI against the
AI approach and our argument for this is
that to test a autonomous system you
need a very intelligent test environment
this intelligent environment is already
being used to test and even train some
of the autonomous cars currently in
development we're hoping this technique
can be broadly used for not only AV
developers but also for Garmin agencies
because they want to make sure these
Anonymous vehicles are safe to be driven
on public road as well and these cars
won't just be able to drive as well as
humans but hopefully even better
accident occurs mostly associated with
human errors
um you know human under influence how
human being distracted by reading cell
phones while while driving Henry hopes
that his research could help developers
fill the roads with self-driving cars
far safer than human drivers but for now
there's a little way to go before
autonomous vehicles can pass their
driving tests
foreign
[Music]